[Music]
[Laughter]
mood naturally fluctuates and everyone
experiences highs and lows in their
lives but in some cases changes in mood
can become long-lasting debilitating and
can impair someone's ability to hold
down a job or sustain meaningful
relationships it's estimated that around
10 percent of people will at some point
in their lives suffer from depression a
mood disorder characterized by several
symptoms feeling sad distressed
unmotivated excessively tired and losing
interest in once pleasurable activities
known as anhedonia many people with
depression also suffer from anxiety
neuroimaging studies reveal that many
brain circuits that normally regulate
mood are dysregulated in depression
located deep within the brain the
amygdala processes highly salient
stimuli such as rewards and potential
threats in depression the amygdala is
overactive and responds excessively to
negative events in turn the amygdala
connects to a set of brain regions that
hone the physiological and behavioral
response to emotional stimuli these
areas include the medial prefrontal
cortex the nucleus accumbens the
hippocampus and the insula the
hippocampus is involved in memory
formation and along with the prefrontal
cortex is particularly vulnerable to the
effects of stress depressed people are
more susceptible to stress which can
cause physical changes in the brain
including atrophy of the hippocampus
this and other changes in depressed
people may cause inappropriate responses
to emotional events
the medial prefrontal cortex is involved
in regulating how strongly we react to
emotional stimuli treatments such as
antidepressant drugs cognitive
behavioral therapy and electroconvulsive
therapy affect the structure and
function of these and other brain
regions
animal models such as mice are critical
in helping us understand the cellular
and molecular changes underlying
depression and develop better treatments
although it's impossible to know if a
mouse is depressed my subjected to
chronic stress show some symptoms
similar to depressed humans such as
anxiety like behavior less social
interaction and a lack of interest in
normally pleasurable activities while
not all human depression is triggered by
stress these models may still shed light
on the biology of depression and they're
the closest scientists can get while
studying mice as with humans
chronic stress in mice can lead to
atrophy of the hippocampus and
prefrontal cortex Mouse studies have
also shown altered neuronal plasticity
in various brain regions including the
hippocampus prefrontal cortex amygdala
and nucleus accumbens in a healthy
hippocampus experiences can lead to
changes in the connections between
neurons resulting in learning these
changes are referred to as plasticity
chronic stress can reduce this
plasticity healthy brains also continue
to produce new neurons in one part of
the hippocampus these new neurons slowly
mature and integrate into the circuitry
where they have a strong effect on
hippocampal activity and behavior these
new neurons are also affected by stress
they reduced in number in stressed
brains these effects may result from
reduced levels of neurotrophins proteins
that increase neuronal growth and
plasticity reduced plasticity may stop
the hippocampus from being able to
properly regulate the stress response
which may lead to a vicious cycle where
stress perpetuates more stress the
hippocampus is particularly affected but
there can be reductions in plasticity
elsewhere in the brain and together
these changes could contribute to other
symptoms of depression like an
dona whether these cellular changes seen
in mice are involved in human depression
remains unclear
most antidepressants available today
rapidly increase the amount of the
neurotransmitters serotonin and/or
norepinephrine in the synapse
however improvements in symptoms in
patients and mice usually don't occur
until weeks after starting the treatment
while the reasons for this delay aren't
fully understood prolonged treatment
with antidepressants can over time act
to reverse some of the changes induced
by chronic stress increasing
neurotrophins expression and rebooting
hippocampal plasticity non-chemical
treatments for depression including
electroconvulsive shock also promote
hippocampal plasticity in mice
antidepressant treatment can also
reverse stress induced changes in other
areas of the brain including the
prefrontal cortex and reward circuitry
different treatments may target
different regions to improve symptoms
recently the drug ketamine was found to
have rapid antidepressant effects in
patients with depression as well as in
rodent models with effects lasting for
days the mechanism behind this is an
area of active research ketamine blocks
a type of synaptic transmission leading
to activation of a number of signaling
pathways an increasing neurotrophins
expression these molecular changes
result in increased plasticity in the
prefrontal cortex and hippocampus and
likely contribute to ketamine's
behavioural effects
by studying the changes in the brain
caused by chronic stress and how
antidepressants like ketamine work to
reverse them
researchers may find new targets for
treatment or new drugs that could act
more quickly more specifically or more
effectively than currently available
treatments
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]